invincible episode
four today i've been loving the hell out
of the show aaron thank you so much for
being here
your presence is oh sorry what thank you
for having me um you'll starve
okay almost interrupted me just for that
so guys go ahead and
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our next
invincible reaction is up also full
length watch along four invincible all
of them are over at our patreon
and we cover a whole bunch of shows
reaction highlights watched all include
for many shows over there too thank you
to everyone to show your support because
believe me
it helps supplement a lot when it comes
to going to tv
editing tv shows for youtube speaking of
which pretty thomas and all thank you
for editing the highlights portion of
this video for us
your help is insurmountably appreciated
anyhow let's get into action people
invincible
[Music]
the time we're filming this is through
the episode fives come out uh here we go
ah you men are too slow
to finish that cigarette
master soon you will once again teach
this world what it means to truly suffer
it's like indiana jones villain meets
steppenwolf
no more like the mummy mother it's a
mummy
oh this is straight up the mommy which
the brendan fraser one was inspired by
indiana jones
[Laughter]
damn good thing you got trapped in there
huh
yeah right
oh yeah more blood oh it's gonna be all
red by the end
did joseph ever lie to you of course all
heroes do
yikes she's only now questioning if he's
ever lied
all this time after 20 years you trust
that mustache
wow dude you were caught smack dab on
camera
cool
it's like hellboy meets rorschach yeah
you too many of them in the philippines
last summer
philippines shout out to philippines
oh who was on the wall back there
wondered if you'd come
you were in my news you
maybe you came to finish the job you
started with the guardians
you're the demon after all and demons
know
evil when they see it
who do you think they're gonna believe
me or you
oh that's true i love him he's my
favorite he's pretty great
wife already suspects how long
until sun does do
go [ __ ] yourself duck blood
[Laughter]
cool uh if i was even walking
yeah i really wanted him to be a little
too higher than the door though so you
just have to go down a little bit and go
back up
we're cool right you mean after you
knocked out three of my teeth and gave
me a concussion
but you know what all those other heroes
total [ __ ] anyway
okay
i hate that please do not allow your
personal and professional lives to
intersect what are you crazy man she
looks like she's 14
besides now that i'm a guardian i can
bang anyone i want
oh god i'm glad we have an understanding
ow
what the hell yeah oh i'm sorry i must
have pinched a nerve
i forget how soft humans are
[Music]
yo robot who are you i don't think he's
actually a robot what's going on
nasa's about to launch the first man
mission to mars i need your father to
shadow the mission
make sure nothing goes wrong only he
won't do it my priority is to my family
and this planet
end of story i guess this is the part
where i volunteer
that's what happened last time you came
here asking dad to go to space yeah that
was the moon
mark that hardly counts us
if the kid wants to go he'd be doing
humanity a favor debbie
help me out here i don't like mark
missing school but
how much school am i really gonna miss i
can zip up to mars and be back tomorrow
the fact that you don't know how far
away mars
is is exactly why you shouldn't
it's a two ignition two weeks dad's
right
i'm not ready things with amber are
going really well
[ __ ] these astronauts
you need to decide what kind of hero you
want to be
oh mark's always having to choose two
weeks to get some mars
i'll do it that was fast a lunch kid
that's some spider-man stuff right there
baby
if you need anything or want to talk
about it i'm here
after i get back from mars i mean once
you tell someone your secret identity
that's it
so if you're gonna tell amber the truth
you better be serious about her
are you serious about her mark she's
like a first girlfriend right i think so
yeah
then you should tell her you'll be
together forever
because that's how it always goes yeah i
figured you need something to store your
rice separator in
that's steal that thank you
i'm you're what volunteering just like
you
i'm going away and helping people for
two weeks what
like far away well that's great when
just under 60 seconds oh god now
any minute now for real where are you
going you know
it's deserty hardly anyone goes there
um amber you're gonna get out of this
man
please don't lose interest in me while
i'm gone i figure you've banked about
two weeks of interest okay yeah she is
so accepting
all right maybe three six oh five
four believe referral i'll bring you
back a souvenir what
and we have liftoff of the mars mission
oh okay he just has a he just has a pack
i thought he'd be like
in the ship with him he has to be
outside to push it
unless in this universe it's different
because here it's two weeks i mean two
years to get to mars
what the hell are you talking about it
takes two years to get to mars
this is how travel works we don't know
much about them
but we know they live underground and
keep to themselves martians
way to bury the lead cecil make sure our
astronauts get home
safe oh the humanity's counting on you
no orchestral sci-fi synth music
the watchtower you're hiding something
from me
and it hurts i never thought i would
have a family
and then you came along and i love you
and mark
so much but when i see mark with his
powers
and after what happened to the guardians
i'm terrified
there's some truth to that i believe him
but why'd he kill everyone weeks and
huh wow mark going away is the best
thing that could have happened for your
relationship oh yeah
you're getting a baby brother
damn why would you that was dumb why
would they think he could do that
why would he why would he think he could
eat a sandwich through a helmet
it's been two weeks already damn that
was
fast
how does he go to the bathroom
did you guys see that see what
never mind alien oh they don't know he's
on the mission
oh he's like secretly accompanying them
now's not the time to touch yourself man
well no who knows what happens to your
junk in space that is a boring ass job
[Music]
they leave that's impressive you can
charge your phone for two weeks
oh you're done goof bro
you're done goofed mark
cut to commercial i'm glad we came
but you still feel something's wrong
don't you i don't know if it's what
happened to the guardians or mark or if
it's just
us but i feel like i'm standing on the
edge of a cliff cecil thinks i had
something to do with
what happened to the guardians but you
didn't
i'm the only survivor and i'm not human
what do we do
we stay together as a family you me and
mark technically didn't lie
yeah do you trust me debbie there's
there's a dragon behind you
please do you trust what the hell
i trust you okay now
i'm on vacation with my beautiful what
the hell
what the hell wow you cold bastard
what do you mean he was with his wife
[Music]
this is how you get
he's playing the long game yeah 25 years
maybe he doesn't remember killing him
are you yawning while we have a camera
pointed us
just because it's midnight doesn't mean
you can yawn
raw unprofessional hope you guys like
the inside of my mouth
here i found it all the evidence to
convict him of allah
[Laughter]
no one warned us about you oh no
we told on him i thought he wanted
him yeah
i shouldn't expect it to happen so soon
why are they sound like that oh
god
what the hell
oh god i'm super ricky morty vibes
yeah i see it
the hell right and exactly what i said
oh
those are his people the vulture mites
no not his people the the weird things i
like to hang with the little girl
just here looking forward oh martian man
yeah yeah yeah marcher man yeah
martian suicides people are here oh wow
there's a whole civilization here
[Music]
what is your purpose here i was sent to
protect some of my fellow earth men
on a mission to your lovely planet and
if they don't get back in one piece
i'm really gonna look like a dick oh
yeah we don't know who that is
if you don't mind we'll get out of your
um hair
and maybe keep your little squid dogs
under control this time
the sequins are the very reason i
captured your people
they are a world destroying race who
left the trail of destruction across the
universe
before crashing onto our planet alone
their group mind is scattered and weak
but with an appropriate host
they become unified and unstoppable okay
but if a single secret
how are you able to resist them i'm part
vultrumite
never heard of us i am the emperor of
mars
of course i've heard of you okay well
then you know we like to help out
wherever we can
which is why i was sent to protect these
assets oh no
is there something that that's not the
reputation i don't think it is
scheduled for immediate execution we
cannot risk them coming encounter
with a secret uh oh he's gonna have to
do some murdering
grab hands people jesus come on
let's do an iron man 3 here
[Music]
the grab hands and do the the parachute
thing and i have three yeah
yeah yeah you guys know
you're just a foreign invader mark
that sounded pretty evil man i think i
can lift that
you gotta carry this ship all the way
back to earth
great plan
so they totally brought back some of
those alien things with them right
hopefully uh-oh yep
oh no
oh no oh
whoa
whoa sounds like this
this mars plot's going to be a lot more
important yeah
okay just sitting in the dark anderson
not doing anything
oh really fast okay
this is that whole scene
guess what donald found when we searched
your
oh he framed him the guardians
yep planted didn't kill guardians
didn't try to kill nolan
but i have to do this anyway
why so because you didn't listen to me
when i told you to drop the goddamn case
it's like a seance dominari demonia
mayhem
well i need to keep things great until i
can figure out why
nolan killed the guardians and how to
stop it
no man he's my favorite
i'm sure he'll be back oh no
still want to know what happened to that
guy's face
i don't trust man tell me what's going
on
who are you bowing to
what oh god finally
phase one begins what
after did you talk to cecil yeah get
this
some new evidence came up and apparently
i'm in the clear he even apologized
cecil never apologizes
i know so nothing to worry about
[Music]
yeah he's in there oh snap in the room
he's in the room like a freaking pervert
or did he plant that
what plan what like when nolan came to
visit him they'd record their
conversation and then plant that in his
house
plan what plant their their conversation
like he was he was sitting sitting at
his desk nolan came up
what if he recorded their conversation
of nolan coming to threaten him
and then plant that tape inside of his
house what's convicting in that tape
didn't he basically confess confess to
murdering him now
no he didn't confess ah i need to
re-watch that scene no these remembers
remember nolan was like maybe you're the
one who killed the guardians
fair yeah fair no it's just facts
it's not an opinion here
but he sounded threatening
it's enough it's very late at night
it's past my bedtime it's fast for both
of our bedtime
that's so good all right man wow please
take it away
lead the conversation my friend well we
saw a whole gang of
goodies in this episode from mark going
to mars
to to a tomb scene in the beginning that
we never go back to
we get some some relationship stuff
some more nolan not caring about
humanity
this time on invincible thanks for the
recap
that's why we're here to read that
that's what you guys all want
to watch it and just say what happened
in a quick little beat
i really loved um everything with debbie
and nolan in this episode actually it
was like the mark and mars stuff that
was the least interesting which looks
like it's going to have
the most consequences moving forward
like i'm sure the effects of whatever
those squid
things are will have a much bigger play
ahead evidently
uh by the sting that's left here
everything on earth was significantly
more interesting
yeah this show trips me out because i
don't know if it's the format or just
the writing of it it
feels written like a live action show
like especially this like the more human
elements of it i could easily see actors
playing the scene the scenes out which
is kind of funny because the
first episode felt very animated in like
its lightness but the the more the show
goes on reveals its two colors
its true colors it kind of there's two
colors
two colors true colors the more it does
those things it kind of
reveals more of the adult nature of it
not not only in the fact that it's more
bloody or more violent but it's more
mature
it handles its characters in a in a very
rich way
it feels like the voice over actors are
actually playing off each other
yes and not like they recorded
separately and they match them together
which
which may be the case like i i have no
idea but at least get the impression
i get what you're getting at i i get the
impression that they're they're like in
the same room
talking with each other as they're
recording this which makes the
back and forth feel that much more
natural yeah especially in the more
human adult conversations that they have
i loved
nolan training mark some more than
really
it really seems to be honing in on the
fact that he's vulture might not gonna
go too much of my own personal
experience about this
and uh i know other people who have
dealt with it too i'm not 100
sure if this is the case sometimes and
it's i don't feel like it's an
interracial commentary but i kind of get
a little vibe of that in the sense of
inner species
mix of like you're not human you're
vulture might i've
experienced this in my own ways i know
other people have two
being half and half of like no you're
only this now it's kind of the
impression i was gonna hear like there
doesn't seem to be any
bit of nolan that wants him to embrace
being human
i could be very much wrong about that he
could just be talking about the vulture
my angle
only to help him further hone in
on his skills like the more aware he is
that he's not human and he's vulture
might he could better adapt to his new
set of skills but there was even that
trigger line
uh when debbie was talking with him
about ever since you found out mark got
powers
and then nolan's like yeah i just want
him to know his people but i don't even
know your people
you know that was interesting yeah so it
seems like it's coming
back to that something specifically
about being vulture mike because we
don't know much about them they seem to
have this glorified past based off what
nolan has said the aliens on mars the
martians
uh did not say anything specific even
though i thought they might
yeah i feel like they let them per he
led him perfectly into a situation where
he would talk about him but it didn't
but i like what you were saying about
him kind of honing in on the fact that
he's he's vulture might you're a vulture
my son
that was something that kind of came to
fruition or came more
to light with uh with nolan because of
the rise of of mark's powers you know
and i thought that was that was a trip
the whole inciting incident of the show
kind of changed nolan's perspective a
clock was set
by mark's powers becoming activated so
his whole demeanors kind of changed and
yeah he never talked about his planet
before mark got his powers i don't know
if he's like that the whole time
but his he seems like a little bit more
um desensitized or
like a like a sociopath not like
homelander level but like
some level of sociopath yeah it seems
like he's learning
human emotions and still after 20 years
yeah after 20 years still learning how
to how to feel empathy or how to
uh even put on the mask of emotions or
feign certain emotions but he seems like
he really cares about debbie
no yeah he does i think i think that's
like the saving
that's the hook of his characters i
don't know maybe the show would go there
they made nolan
uh remarkably mysterious to the point
where you're like i don't really know
what this guy's ever thinking maybe he
is the kind of guy who would kill his
family if he needed to
you know uh it doesn't seem like it now
but the show seems like it wouldn't hold
any punches back
if they needed to go there i don't know
honestly i want them to die i'm just
saying i think it would be cool if the
show
really pushes the envelope in that
direction but debbie specifically and
she's been
fine you know she's charming whenever
she's on screen
this was the first episode where i
really cared about her where i really
felt like she was an essential character
to this journey and i love the tidbits
of dialogue about how like
we're falling and i'm the only one who
can't fly her having to have her
suspicions about her husband after all
these years her feelings of concern
for the olga the russian woman for the
russian woman being in this realm of
uncertainty
and being aware that you are the only
human you're caught in the middle
between
husband and son who both have
superpowers i thought her dynamic is
it was much more appealing this time
around the demon
guy damien dark blood dark is it dark
wood
yeah dark cold is marvel okay dark
blood dark blood saves right there on
screen
it's right there in case you you didn't
know uh yeah so it's pause right at the
end too anyway
damian darkblood his character i cared
the most about
every time dark blood is on screen i am
incredibly captivated by his presence
the whole time he's in such a tough spot
all nolan has to say is it's it's
dark blood and plant enough like one
little piece of evidence and yeah i mean
come on
look at dark blood look at his past look
who he's a demon it's easy to convict
him love the film of our angle to him
but he is kind of like the beast in
beauty and the beast
you know i don't know he's the one who
really cares you know he's
he's been with the actual heart
interesting to have the character with
the most dark the darkest aesthetics
seem to be the one who cares the most
yeah about the situation at hand it's
that that contrast thing again coming
into play
the gray the gray gray as cecil
talks about i like cecil a lot yeah he
seems like this universe is
like gray version of like nick fury or
something i think it's cool
i wonder what happened to his face uh
walter goggins
doesn't sound like him unless i i'm just
not remembering his voice
huh oh wow walton goggins huh oh anyway
yeah it's a cool mystery man
yeah i dig it it's a cool mystery the
mars stuff wasn't
was not that interesting to me i like
the
context surrounding it of this is why
this is the reasons like this why nolan
i mean maybe there's deeper reasons but
you know like nolan it never became a
guardian wanted to work for someone so
you have to do [ __ ] errands like
this
yeah yeah the whole thing of what mark
had to go through felt like
very much not filler but the stepping
stone event we had to watch
that was entertaining but not the most
engaging a stepping stone event we had
to watch
to set the stakes for what's gonna
happen or play out through the rest of
the season
the one the criticism that i kind of
been having with the show is i don't
feel much for and i've kind of said this
since the second episode i think i don't
get any sense really of the stakes at
hand of
mark has a personal life outside of
being a superhero
there doesn't really seem they said they
even set him up for
clashes oh you're gonna go to mars for
two weeks he just started dating amber
it's going good there's this kind of
lamborghini it's like whatever about it
yeah he comes back it's fine you know
like doesn't ask questions and comparing
it to something like spider-man that's
part of the
the fun is how much you feel for like he
has to keep his identity secret and he
and like oh i want him to succeed in his
personal life too and he's got obstacles
there but the superhero lifestyle is
pulling him away from fulfilling
personal life
obstacles and relationships and living
up to the fullest potential there and
here
it you don't really get the sense of
pressure or
um or how much of a toll it takes on him
yeah in his personal life
i know he just started being a superhero
but everything just kind of does seem to
be a little bit
pretty easy going forward in this
personality life yeah i feel like
i and again don't know the comics but i
thought this
the early stages of this character's
journey or adventures very much having
the training wheels on before [ __ ] gets
real because we knew he's gonna have
that confrontation with his dad
you know he's gonna like uncover some
some really dark stuff because
yeah we're just seeing him learn how to
be a superhero it's a trip cause
we have all these different moving
pieces of the show i care about the
characters and i care about the things
that are happening but like it doesn't
feel focused i want to say it feels like
a lot of different things are happening
i am enjoying all the different pieces
of things that are happening i just
can't wait for them to all come to a
head yeah i feel like all coalesce
together in the end yeah now at days
with shows you got to judge them by the
season
but the episode sometimes
this is one of those shows where you're
like you're going to judge it by the
by the overall story of season one right
in the end it might all come together
because i like mark like i enjoy mark a
lot and he's very
humorous and funny but i think i'd be
more drawn to him it felt like
the stuff outside of him doing super
stuff
would have a little bit more tension to
it yeah
you know like if he was like oh my god i
wanted amber my like imagine a scenario
like i've wanted amber my whole life
or for other years now or something i've
always wanted to date her be with her
now
now's my chance but oh but i also got to
be a superhero and i can't tell amber
and i feel like
i'm letting this opportunity of the love
of my life slip away because
i have to be a suit you know what i mean
yeah yeah but amber's always like
okay
[Laughter]
yeah like we're four episodes in we're
like halfway through the season already
yeah
it's like even the mom's like you know
i'm not a fan of him missing school but
what a better reason to skip school
than to do some superhero like a
conflict because parts of it feel
refreshing
because a lot of what i'm pitching are
tropy and familiar that's the thing is
i'm pitching these like familiar
elements right i think some familiar
doesn't mean bad though
however there's the refreshing side of
oh it's kind of nice to see the mom just
be kind of supportive about the whole
thing
yeah it's refreshing because i feel like
there's there's a lot of
other moving pieces that are maybe given
more
stake-wise like i think the the whole
garden to the globe thing is where the
stakes
and consequences come in but for mark's
early journey they're kind of
keeping it like light and fluffy around
him for a show called invincible he
doesn't
they can main character invincible
doesn't have a lot of of those
kind of trials and tribulations yeah
soon i'm willing to bet
it's gonna be one of those things where
like by the end of the season is like
when shit's really gonna hit the fan for
him and he's gonna have a rough second
season
yeah yeah i'm really enjoying the hell
out of the show mainly have positives to
say it's usually this one thing i keep
coming back to
we hate it no no no no no no we don't
hate it we don't need it no no
it is that one part of the mark journey
that that's missing for me because even
because even for no one they have it in
here for nolan like i'm trying to be a
husband
i'm trying to be trying to be a dad i'm
trying to be here for my wife right now
instead of just being a superhero
you know all the characters are
interesting to me and i do enjoy mark
and i do
do enjoy invincible but i feel like out
of the supporting characters i feel like
he's the one
that's like not my my priority for like
he's not my favorite character thus far
i think the i think a lot of the
surrounding characters are more
interesting
yeah they're the ones i want to keep
cutting back to and like mark i
i mainly enjoy when he's being funny
or doing cool stuff yeah i wish the show
had more room for
for him and get to see getting to see
him grow as
as a hero because granted we do get
pieces of that but i feel like i feel
like he's barely in this episode
yeah but like and i know he's like
training but it seems like four episodes
and he's like already traveling all the
way
like to mars it looks like he's got a
pretty good handle on all the journey
yeah doing fine he's fine he's taking on
a whole bunch of martians and
yeah he's showing himself damn he's just
doing pretty good for
like a couple weeks of training yeah the
show even said he doesn't have any
responsibilities and his first
responsibility is going to mars
yeah there's some angles too here but
i'm waiting i'm waiting to
completely get my stamp of judgment on
it there's one thing with these
with these shows i i i noticed i don't
have a criticism early on and then
like i have a difference of opinion by
the time the season ends it's like the
next episode [ __ ] immediately
yeah like for the boys season two i
hated maeve
you could watch that journey on youtube
uh
hey to maeve i sort of spent many times
just criticizing her
and then by the last episode i found
myself going like
like cheering for urgent nowadays of tv
it's a little different you got to wait
until like the end of a season
uh for certain things to be like all
right no i have a problem with this
right now
i still think it's a brilliant series
and refreshing and
uh one that stands out as something
unique in the landscape of
oversaturation and superhero shows oh my
god everything's superheroes
too much too much so good
too much very nice
nuts oh i'm not dying you're dying
oh oh i'm not dying but you're not dying
well technically every second we live is
one second closer to our death
that is so beautifully bleak
no there's nothing beautiful about that
makes me wonder what the point of living
is
there's no point this is the end
last
[Laughter]
last but not least
you know i'm gonna shout today david
gandy you met david
didn't i remember at my uh
arena cine lounge thing where john and i
did the q a thingy
the films yeah remember that yes david
drove
six hours he was the white dude who sat
in the front row who drove six hours to
be there he met him for sure for sure
you met him
oh wow but you don't remember him
because you're racist
vaguely i man i've
that's awesome that's awesome that you
did that and it was cool that we both
got to be at that same event
you know it's also awesome people always
ask me where did i get
this attack on titan jacket
who constantly asked me greg i got to
know where you got it get messages on
instagram
constantly comments whenever i go
through taco bell drive-thru
this lady is always like [ __ ]
i'm like she never remembers me and i'm
like i'm greg alba from the real
rejects looking face mask off oh i'm not
giving you
your food now because you took your mask
off fine
i'll go to another taco bell and then i
just go back around
and she's like oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
david you've been incredibly giving in
more ways than one and i miss you
and i know we haven't talked in a while
and it's all my fault i just want you to
know that
you mean a lot to me and i'll never
forget you buddy thank you oh it's very
sweet
it's very sincere yeah i might change a
shout out just take that moment apply to
someone else
yeah yeah copy and paste copy and paste
yeah
just everyone's shout outs just gonna
have that same cut next to john
let's cut to here but i want you to keep
those words but
like 80 aren't really badly